mira
[Música]
de salud adentro mejía with the headlines
for today wednesday december 30 the
police are investigating a homicide in the
west of the valley according to the authorities a
son shot and killed his father in a
house near another and week it is
reported that the  father got into a fight and
beat son and left the scene when he
returned the son shot and killed him
at this time it is unknown if
the son will be charged in other news
that unfolded last night there was a
fire in a warehouse near the hotel
scratch on industrial street at
about midnight where homeless people usually
camp the two-alarm incident took
two hours to contain and it was reported that
one person suffered minor burns
investigators estimate the damage at one
million dollars new year's eve
is tomorrow and  after the suspension of
the big end of the year party in the
script the police will now be watching
and despite the fact that there will be no
fireworks in the tourist area in
downtow  n a certain amount of people will be allowed
to walk in the freemont sweet
experience they will charge 25 dollars
to cover security charges and there
will be no live entertainment and if you are
planning to be on the strip or
downtown these items
will be prohibited bottles  or
glass containers large bags
luggage and strollers and now a look
at the weather forecast after the
strong winds we had yesterday today
we will have a lot of sun and generally
light wind tomorrow new years eve
I expect an increase in winds and clouds with
the maximum temperatures
Around 55 degrees, have a nice day,
say hello to Héctor Mejía and this was his
brief news broadcast in Spanish
[Music]